foreign
foreign
what is your connection to dance
do you love the ballet or maybe you
watch those dance competitions on
television
or did you jump into
the horror at the bar mitzvah one time
I want you to reconsider your connection
to dance
because I believe it to be a simple and
successful way of accessing happiness
Within
what do you need to participate
virtually nothing
but your will to explore and have a
little bit of fun
no music no partner required
when I choreographed for film television
or commercials I often generate moves
that are based on The Human Experience I
take these moves and I stream them
together
twist and play with their Pace in order
to create more meaningful work
let me show you what I mean
here's a music video Chandelier that I
choreographed for Sia featuring The
Incredible dancer Maddie Ziegler
[Music]
now let's play the video one more time
and I want to show you what inspired
those moves you may be surprised at how
rudimentary the sources are
and Fork Fork Fork stabbed in the wall
toss it and pass out come to and look
Charlie Chaplin Charlie Chaplin
cockroach up the wall clean your
mustache a possum sink
is it time for lunch yet
see thanks
see even a cute little cockroach can
inspire a dance move but it really is
that easy
and look
most people can't dance like Maddie
including myself
and that's the point
we all have our own beautiful ways of
moving and this is worth celebrating
it's time to extract the Judgment out of
our Dance Experience
and set free the preconceived notion of
what good dance is
and instead
find out how your own body loves to move
and find out that
inner Rhythm that feels so good
think more body
less critique
so you may ask well how do I access or
unlock this dance magic well once you
have the perspective that life is dance
yeah
you'll begin to see dance everywhere
around you all day long like I do
like now
witness how you're sitting in front of
me
your posture
are both feet grounded
is one leg crossed over the other
where are your hands placed
or envision
a parent rocking their child
it's a playful flourish right
tying your shoe
a grand gesture
drinking a glass of water
the stylized Head release
so check out this proof of concept
in the first week of the worldwide
lockdown in March 2020
I decided to teach us online
follow-along dance class called
sweatfest
let's hope
I was hoping a couple friends would join
in but
over the course of the next couple of
weeks tens of thousands of people from
all over the world joined sweatfest
turning our Collective isolation into a
worldwide community
it was absolutely beautiful
people check their critical minds and
really Unleashed that Joy from within
doing these goofy dance moves
while the world is in disarray
take a look
[Music]
who would have guessed that moves like
the Pretty Pony and the Bob Ross would
be so life-changing
so I've been a student of dance for 42
years my relationship with the art form
runs deep and quite intimate
this helped me through trauma it has
paid my rent but most of all it's been
an unfaltering joy in my life
and that's why I'm here because I
believe there's more joy for you
only steps away
via simple and rudimentary moves that
you already know
so I'd love to invite you to be your own
choreographer
grab your kids or go solo and let fun
and laughter push the boundaries of
Ridiculousness
who knows maybe brushing your teeth or
whiskey and mac and cheese will become
your new favorite dance move
and once you have a dance move or two or
three or four under your belt
respectfully call yourself a dancer
because you've earned it
and share
those moves and that happiness with
those around you
because a world with more dance is a
world with more joy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you